av vous comment il va le
[Musique]
PE en pleine
forme ce sera pas une graine de voou
comm
Mo si te ressemble ça serait
bien faire
unqu il fera ce qu'il veudra
ah il a envie de braquer il ira braquer
peut-être j'ira avec lui
d'ailleurs
ok ça change quoi pour toi un mec qui a
32 ans de plus que
[Musique]
toi suivez mon
regard et bien je pense que ça permet
des rapports privilégiés et
inviolabl waouh tu serait pas un tellot
sur les
bords h
peêtre à ton contact je sais pasêre
contagieux je sa pas comme disais JV
vous pouvez me serrer la main jeune
homme le tal n pas
contagieux ça te fait quoi d'avoir un
enfant avec l'arrière niè général
Paulus c'est une beauté ce
petit si j était l'héroïne de Melody
Nelson est-ce que moi je suis samanta
l'héroï
de
samanta ses yeux gris demuré grand
ouvert lorsque je bais
baisis lorsque je baisais sa bouche
close dites vous connaissez le parfum
soleil ver tiens vous êtes français je
suppose ça c'est de Nabokov mais je suis
un piqueur je un
ESC mais oui tu ça
quelque
part tu crois qu'on va rester longtemps
ensemble AUC tous les
deux mathématiquement
parlant je risque de casser ma pipeant
toi je l'père pour toi donc tu me
perdras un jour dans ce sens là
c'est cruel c'est
mathématique mathématique pas
élémentaire
mon tu crois que tu ser avec qui siéta
pas
rencontré je pense que
pog
compris
mais
on ça suffit une
perce pour l'instant c'est toi je crois
que tu la dernière de sera la dernière
de ma vie ma petite cocotte minute
ohon et toi tu ferais quoi qu tu
branlerais si on s'était pas
rencontré je sais pas du tout je sais
pas si je suis encore là enfin il y a
plein de choses que je sais pas j'aurais
eu un destin complètement tu faire r je
sais pas je t'ai marqué au fer rouge là
et là
à qu'est-ce qui t'énerve le plus chez
moi
ah tu es saut d'humur on dirait des
électrocardiogrammes tu peux parler
parce que toi c'est pire que
moi je t'ai déjà cassé la gueule
tu te rappelles pas le
SOLAS ah mais moi je je suis un je plus
et moi je prends les couteaux ah ouais
joue du couteau puis dans
le tu ferais quoi si Je te
[Musique]
quittais une t
si tu me
quittais je te dire une chose ma petite
cocotte tu serais pas la
première tu ser peut-être la
dernier c'est pas demain la veille parce
que je vais les
pinces accrocher
radiateur
faire ta
gueule
chier tu bouges pas de
là ça t'a fait chier quand c'est tirer
avec
to
com touche
pas qui
touable c'estàd ma vie perce
c'est vrai qu'au début des années 60 tu
t'es marié avec une princesse
[Musique]
galtine belle
garce on peut partager en
[Musique]
deux une
belle une g mais avec qui tu as
eu coup de merde avec les les questions
pers je dis j'is pas rester plus
sa parce que je me ti les
barbes ou mais si tu t'es marié
c'est que c'est que c'est que c'est que
jou au con tout c'est la Seu connerie
qui Fa tu m'as dit c'est à partir du
moment tu t'es marié ça commencé à
déconner c'est pour ça que tous les deux
on est à
l'école tu
maimes
moi non
plus c'est
facile prendre les femmes pour ce
qu'elles ne sont pas et les laisser pour
ce qu' alors explique-moi
[Musique]
çaliite je te laisserai
pas je te prends toi pour ce que tu n'es
pas mais je te prends aussi pour ce que
tu
great